all right let's let's right out of the
gate I just want to address something
that you know it was really [ __ ]
annoying this [ __ ] out of me
so this [ __ ] guy right he was a flat
earther but I gotta be honest with you
where did these people come from who you
know it was proven like we were flat
earthers and then somebody finally said
wait a minute it's it's round and then
the church decided to kill the guy right
oh no way he when he said the Sun was
the center of the [ __ ] solar system
and it's like no what the earth is we
are because God made us like in his
[ __ ] thing his image right wasn't
something like that I don't know I don't
[ __ ] know
but anyway we kind of sailed around it
pointed in one direction and came back
on the other side and these guys are
trying to say I don't understand why
what is the benefit to lying what is the
endgame we have to tell them it's round
man why I get all the other ones saying
that money has value saying these people
are evildoers saying these people just
want to give it to the poor saying these
people just want to keep all the money I
get I understand the motives in that I
just don't know what is what is flat
earthers let me ask you this flat flat
earthers are the same people that would
watch one of those [ __ ] Netflix
documentaries in like you know I don't
think that guy did it in a buddy of mine
one time [ __ ] he watched that stupid
curtain and Courtney Love documentary
and by the end of it they had convinced
him that Courtney Love killed Kurt
Cobain and I was sitting there going to
do you really think that a [ __ ] drug
addict from three states away
a [ __ ] organized a hit in the Seattle
Police Department couldn't figure that
out haven't you watched the first 48 you
ever see a mobster on that now you see a
bunch of [ __ ] dopes who killed
somebody for the first time getting
caught anyway
why the [ __ ] would she kill him he he
wrote our whole album makes no sense so
flat earthers I don't understand can
somebody explain to me cuz I'll be
honest with you I don't know if the
Earth's around okay any more than
anybody else does all these [ __ ]
people are going dude look the more its
route you're doing that you're you you
know it's round not cuz you figured it
out alright you know it's round cuz
somebody told you it was round everybody
acting like they [ __ ] built their own
steam rocket went out in the [ __ ] air
well you took a flight to Disneyland and
that's what you would check it now you
wouldn't even checking it out I'll tell
you this right now when you when you
when you fly it when you actually fly
commercially you can't tell it the earth
is round I think if you're sitting up
front you can you can't look out the
side of the [ __ ] thing I don't know
what you're seeing but I don't see
anything that says it's definitely flat
or it's definitely [ __ ] round I know
it's [ __ ] round because the goddamn
astronauts who have [ __ ] balls you
know that have been you know you know
looks [ __ ] that guys come back from
space and the whole thing everything
burns up you know if they [ __ ] up
everything that the design [ __ ]
everything burns up we except for the
balls of the person on that [ __ ]
thing yeah they took the pictures and
like well there it is there it is I've
never tried to sail around the world you
know and looked at my compass to make
sure I was still headed west and I kept
heading west and all of a sudden I was
back in my driveway again alright I'm
just like you I know it's round because
smarter people figured it out people
died and then they
[ __ ] told me what was right okay and
I choose to believe it I've flown around
the world not all at once but you know I
slept for a lot of it how do I know he
didn't [ __ ] turn around so this gets
me to this Team Rocket guy sorry I'm
drinking tea I'm an old man here all
right so this [ __ ] guy rather than
just being like you and me who just
accept what these [ __ ] people tell us
is true all right and know that know
that you know that it's [ __ ] round
because somebody taught you that not cuz
you figured it out the amount of [ __ ]
[ __ ] on social media the way they're
going off on this Team Rocket guy about
cuz he believed the world was flat these
[ __ ] [ __ ] who've never
accomplished anything in their [ __ ]
life like let me ask you okay so this
[ __ ] guy if you don't know this story
he builds a [ __ ] steam rocket which I
don't even know how the [ __ ] you do that
I have no idea how to do that this guy
knew how to do that he got himself into
it when it took off I guess the
parachute ripped off and he was flying
all the way up into the [ __ ] air
which by the way I don't know what radio
call you make in aviation that you're
gonna [ __ ] do that be a reverse lawn
dart and just go straight up in the
[ __ ] air I guess they were filming a
TV show so I would like to think some
producer called somebody to make sure
they weren't going to hit a [ __ ]
commercial flight with [ __ ] 400
people on it 300 people on it right so
he shoots up in the air the parachute
comes off you only feel like right now I
feel like one of those [ __ ] youtube
stars you know how they always do these
intros that you just don't need it's
like I just want to see the video like
you know oblivious okay so these [ __ ]
guys go to steam rocket right like how
do you make that just show the [ __ ]
guy taking off right sorry it's a
podcast so I guess I get away with it
so the [ __ ] thing takes off very
impressive velocity something flies off
it evidently it was the parachute he got
up there
it's okay to be enough in all fairness
this guy for all I know he proved that
the world was [ __ ] flat with his
goddamn pictures I've never been as high
up as this guy when allegedly you know
I've never checked it all out all right
I went into a science class they told me
it was [ __ ] round so I said yeah it's
round so I would pass the [ __ ] test
so I didn't have to go to [ __ ] summer
school but I know I never fact checked
it you know this post me to era where
he's supposed to vet everything this
guy's vet and [ __ ] right so he [ __ ]
shoots up in the air the goddamn
parachute comes off and I guess I don't
know if he knew it at the time I hope he
didn't know it so remember he was up
there on the way up he had a good time
took some selfies when he was excited
that he proved that it was flat and then
he was coming all the way back down I
can't believe the [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
gonna get now that I'm the guy that
[ __ ] told caperna said Copernicus is
that the guy to go [ __ ] Magellan to go
[ __ ] himself
Santa Maria and he [ __ ] they died so
what happens what does everybody do
everybody goes on the internet and they
start [ __ ] laughing at this guy
talking about this guy like he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] people who are in a
[ __ ] cubicle who don't have a dream
who aren't leaders who've never made
anything [ __ ] happen in their life
not even a [ __ ] lemonade stand
all right this isn't that judging this
guy and they're doing that you know
Darwinism or [ __ ] you know the whole
[ __ ] whatever that stupid nature
thing is where it's like this this what
does the [ __ ] is that the strongest
people survive you know natural
selection in all of this [ __ ]
let me ask all you [ __ ] [ __ ] that
are making fun of this guy who had balls
of [ __ ] steel let me ask you this
who's smarter actually ask me like this
a guy who thinks the world is flat and
builds a steam rocket that shoots
himself up into the [ __ ] air and he
dies or the guy who doesn't know how to
build a steam rocket and doesn't get in
it and doesn't really [ __ ] do
anything in life other than not
I until he just croaks of old age who
Sue's [ __ ] smart are you just smarter
cuz you're still alive
I mean he [ __ ] up the amount of
[ __ ] brilliant people we've always
[ __ ] astronauts who died trying to
get [ __ ] orbit the earth and all of
that [ __ ] do you think they're [ __ ]
morons I mean everybody's like um
there should be no [ __ ]
do-it-yourself [ __ ] you know rocket
[ __ ] thing or whatever the hell they
say it's just like why not
NASA's had the exact same [ __ ]
problems and it costs the taxpayers
billions of dollars when this [ __ ] blows
up god bless this guy he did a start I
lost no money on that one all right and
he was trying to do flat-earthers a
solid and then all of these [ __ ]
[ __ ] you might be one of those [ __ ]
sitting there laughing at this [ __ ]
guy you want to laugh at him I get it
it's kind of funny but to sit there and
talk about him like he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
the guy made a [ __ ] rocket he had a
malfunction but like I said sort of sort
of NASA numerous occasions so what are
they all dumb at NASA I don't get it
I was [ __ ] amazed I like when I when
I saw that thing take off I could like
thank [ __ ] guy built that thing it
had the balls to get in by the way 99%
of the [ __ ] that you use every day
somebody [ __ ] died as they were
figuring out how to [ __ ] how'd it
make it happen any sort of
transportation anything that moves
Planes Trains boats [ __ ] anything
rockets the amount of [ __ ] people
that died so your dumb ass that the only
thing you know is what the [ __ ] you read
but you've never [ __ ] you've never
broken any ground yourself go easy on
that guy he's [ __ ] dead have a little
[ __ ] respect for the guy
I don't even you make fun I'm gonna give
a [ __ ] you make fun of him but don't
[ __ ] talk about him like he's a [ __ ]
you know unless you're gonna [ __ ] on you
and you're [ __ ] boring
life what the [ __ ] are you doing why am
I talking to you guys like you are all
people on that threat I should be you
know I'm talking the [ __ ] [ __ ]
who trashed this guy natural selection
and you know what's I [ __ ] love about
it if somebody always says that somebody
then it's the exact same [ __ ] memes
anytime a name is trending oh my god
thank God I thought the person was dead
and then they got the stupid Denzel meme
how many [ __ ] times can can you do
that before you just like why would I
why would I subject people to this again
unless you're doing it just to annoy
people you know like all the people are
now gonna send me that meme thinking
that I'm not realizing that you're gonna
do that which by the way I never check
my [ __ ] feet anymore this is what I
check it when like occasion I check it
but then I also when I have something
that's coming so if you want to get me
it's it's right after I have something
come out because I do a quick survey I
scroll like two pages and then I just do
the math like all right what percentage
of that was positive okay that sound
seems like it's a good thing all right I
missed the [ __ ] mark on that one or
something but rest in peace steam rocket
flat earther guy I don't know I don't
know what to tell you I could tell you
right now that guy is smarter than I am
you know I I there's nothing I've ever
done in my life that is the equivalent
of what the [ __ ] that guy did in the
last [ __ ] ten minutes of his life none
of you guys are ever gonna feel that or
myself that level of [ __ ] adrenaline
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] he ate his own
goddamn TV show
this guy's [ __ ] fascinating to me
[ __ ] fascinating why would you just
tap out on he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
he's a [ __ ] more amount of people
that text while driving myself included
any moment could take out a school bus
full of [ __ ] kids right a sitting
there calling this guy of [ __ ] [ __ ]
as you drive to work every day what do
you see on the side of the road reads
and crosses and frosted [ __ ] bikes I
don't know this isn't all just that this
is also I'm kind of dealing with [ __ ]
show business right now I've been doing
some [ __ ] and I just like just it's not
even show business it's just business
the amount of stealing that goes on and
[ __ ] business it's just it's so
[ __ ] gross so [ __ ] gross and I
swear to god it's always some [ __ ]
hundred and fifty five hundred sixty
pound [ __ ] little [ __ ] [ __ ] who's
never gotten a [ __ ] kicked out of in
life and now it's never gonna [ __ ]
happen right because this [ __ ]
cameras everywhere
so the [ __ ] beating that this person
should be taking they're never gonna
[ __ ] take I swear to god it's either
that or it's some fat [ __ ] in a goddamn
suit you don't even realize how fat he
is until the company picnic what he
actually has to wear a t-shirt and he
takes off that layers of [ __ ]
haberdashery and his big dumb [ __ ]
love handles unreal unreal and you know
what business rewards it rewards those
same [ __ ] people who've never done
anything and [ __ ] on this Team Rocket
guy those people who just [ __ ] just
sit there and don't get themselves
killed they don't have a vision they're
not taking any risk they're not leaders
they're just [ __ ] they're agreeing
and saying what they have to say those
[ __ ] people ascend Oh God freckles is
in a [ __ ] mood today
you